per tutti ragazzi e per questo video
sono felice oggi sono dati sul pil wales
in questi episodi finali di fine anno
vediamo ammessi prendo subito giacconi
realista volta che hanno un che di
interessanti poi 50.90 4 13 per cento
impossible
ok you are not going to him to you are
not going to conoscermi misa perché
sennò non scriveresti sta roba però
proviamoci nuova domenica nuovo avanzi a
rivivere allora ed porca vacca c'è una
mia c'era una mina non tocchiamo le mie
andiamo avanti però vedere se riesco a
fare qualcosa di decente tipo saltare lì
non è così facile comunque la mia vita
fa schifo però posso sempre migliorare
signori
fermi tutti
spero che mia madre guardi questo video
perché sarebbe si era di me grazie
cristina per questo splendido livello
let's go by folk short che senso
uno spy for per nani ecco però il corano
è corto perché lo spike ok aspettavo che
non vuol dire tanto ragazzi di spa i
suoi torti non vuol dire che siamo
felici semplicemente sono più facili
volevo dire presidente sono più veloci
da fare però un'altra difficoltà è
sempre quella perché tanto devi sempre
centrare un punto solo quindi parkour
jump con sé stessi e volevo gettarmi
tipo così sicuro fa volare a pinto la
mia ma come è possibile che si sia
divisa a metà la mia 23 biava come che
non è una mietitrebbia ma fa niente
cos'è questa cosa che vedo allora salto
decente non è un sacco di gente questa
manovra non fa niente ci riuscirà a fare
un buon punteggio quando c'è poca spinta
per le prove del cisco lanciarmi l'aqua
questa è buona
ultimate happy with god posso fare di
meglio i ragazzi posso fare di meglio
questo è di meglio ad esempio chuck
norris porca vacca ma si può arrivare
alla fine o non c'è un finale va beh
provate a central e ultima volta
rimanendo vivo che non è facile ai
ragazzi attenzione però a rimanere vivo
mi va bene hacker ragazzi mi va bene sa
che minecraft 2 finalmente hanno fatto
uscire il seguito di minecraft era ora
brest z a choose your mom
ok
spider
[Musica]
ah ok sono sono un ragno di minecraft va
bene quindi sa io vado a ce li vedo
bello vabbè sembra proprio il minecraft
porca vacca non tema ichri per perché
sono anch'io un mostro quindi fa niente
i ragni microsoft ragazzini mi sono solo
una parte parte tre no no mi va bene
minecraft bello comunque seguito di
minecraft degno del predecessore
complimenti dicevo io non è che se non
ho mai capito i ragni minecraft perché
in altra sede
cos'è sta roba che di giorno non ti
attaccano in of the seas ma che sia
meglio non sono coerenti cioè che schifo
altun doge ok vedo subito che c'è una
mina qua dietro quindi o provare a fare
così
va bene non ho neanche toccato il
traguardo e profughi dei clown fare
qualcosa di decente con hope singoli e
vi sono per il natale il natale fatto al
rock swing
c'è questo è proprio il natalizio con
livello buon natale a tutti i ragazzi
buone buone feste
buone feste godetevi sti giorni non dato
a scuola come io me li sono goduti negli
ultimi sei anni
mi ricordo quando andavo in vacanza
quando andavo a scuola e quando andava
in vacanza che cosa significavano per me
le vacanze l'incredibile cioè le vacanze
di natale le vacanze estive mi ancora di
più in crisi il fatto di non fare niente
per tre mesi la mamma mia ragazzi c'è
questa roba vela invidio perché una
bella sensazione però allo stesso tempo
non invidio tutti gli altri giorni di
scuola polino li invidio va bene ci
siamo
devo stare qua dentro tutto sto casino
per spetta che babbo natale 6 sono un
babbo natale qualcuno di fuori è tutto
ok tutto come doveva andare mammamia un
fenomeno bello natalizio sto livello ok
ho più gioia è certo che lo ingoiato
courcelles level su inside stand diamond
rubare il diamante questo vorrei ma non
era un livello di disti stick management
vi ricordate arresti è un livello di
artisti come questo
la prima nata davanti a te cosa succede
muoio chiedete devo arrivare al sì vabbè
però non è che potesse mettere come
sistema di sicurezza lo capì normale
tipo dei laser che chiamano la polizia
nonché lanciano artioli magari entra il
codice l'inserviente che deve pulire e
si vede riuscito ma lascia qualcosa c'è
un bottone il link per youtube si serve
un edizione per disattivare gli avvii
era nascosto volete nascondere però non
è che lo schiacciare col mouse
no ci arrivo ma ci arrivo no non ci
arrivo c'è un bottone nascosto non me ne
vado finché non scopro che cos'è e cosa
ho fatto
e dire che sono sei anni che registro è
più anzi 7
io la mia vita l'ho presa e l'ho buttata
nel cesso nel cesso le domeniche io l'ho
buttata nel cesso o gesù grazie mamma
mia
un'ora e mezza di livello mamma mia
quanto mi sono impegnato per fare sta
roba che va bene sui side anna baker
level ko
all
ok
non avevo avevo intuito il adesso
intuito il santa brigida berta è nave di
l'avrei messa come canzone però poi mi
copyright anno anche se capri ponte mio
amico meno capire che lo stesso che il
porco il demonio morto e chi l'ha fatto
cioè proprio difficile tenere la
aggrapparsi a una roba che hai davanti
fra tema donec scarso come la morte
aspetta non riesco e devo trovare il
modo di sono rivolto verso l'altra parte
girati a capire era difficile arriva in
questa posa vallo tu no dovevo grappa
rmili dovevo farmi tirati su bye bye bye
bye va o amen sono blu e da badie daba
daba però il problema non è questo prima
aggrapparsi a tutte le rock rob corde
swing devo fare io
molto bene il santa volevo augurare
innanzitutto buon natale no perché io in
genere sono una persona che ama il
natale nel senso io minati io quando ero
piccolo facevo la letterina a babbo
natale poi ho sempre fatto il calendario
della benchè insomma io il natale è una
festa che mi vivo da sempre bella festa
i regali tutto un atmosfera natalizia
sempre è unica come poche altre feste al
mondo del natale è l'unica festa che mi
piace così tanto zombie apocalypse
io non ho capi ap il do not go fest a
devo devo sparare come sparo
mi scusi e come come va bene funziona
bene quest'arma come dovrei sparare e
scusami altro andare lì sotto
bella comunque buon pistola c'è nessuna
solo maneggiare si vede bella è
diventato un jetpack sono solo se ve ne
siete accorti va la pistola non la so
neanche impugnando la sto in schierando
bravo vai vai vai vai vai vai di
perfetto sono morte non è vero ha posto
zombie apocalypse 14 per grava fatti già
13 prima pensate come li va bene sto
livello style formare de una caduta
dalle scale tanto io sono nonno
tagliente come pensi che passa non
sopravvivere una caduta dalle scale
così credo è esattamente così però
proviamoci di nuovo strano perché il
rancio dovrebbe attutire la caduta
cosa che non è proprio servita però va
bene c'era bravo non ti fai valere
sempre la mousse out our code mario beh
è stata una mossa alquanto strano però
sono riuscito credo o la testata porte
blue room bellissimo
madonna
questa è una roba che non si può mettere
su youtube inutile rifare l'ultimo
ragazzi non si riesca a fare qualcosa di
decente magari un che di c1 imposti con
il prossimo prossimo ok mettiamo by
newell's ok cioè il prossimo al 100 per
cento per c'è grande successo
ok non so è ben vero male che natalizio
anche questo siamo un po un pacco regalo
gigante
però posso cambiare sharks posso farlo
con nonno ciak con i razzi madonna come
l'ho fatto bene ho capito lo fa niente
spero mi sia piaciuto ragazzi questo vi
auguro buone feste a tutti quanti come
come si usa fare data non me ne frega
niente ma sto scherzando spero vi sia
piaciuto un bacino a tutti iscriviti al
canale schiacciatela campanellina prima
della giocati sui nomi non riescono e
noi come sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]